50 that's how many apps are available in
Android Market as Google Play was known
when it first launched alongside the
first Android device in 2008 a few days
later Android Market opened for all app
developers to register and start
publishing their apps without any review
or validation requirements from Google
OMS or carriers for us as developers the
ability to distribute apps and the
possibility of monetizing them through
upfront payments in-app billing and
advertising directly to the owners of
over a billion Android devices is one of
the most exciting opportunities made
possible by the Android ecosystem
growing up in the dark days before
smartphones in the internet if I wanted
a new game or app I had to go to a
physical store and pay for a cardboard
box filled with floppy discs or CD ROMs
as developers a big part of our business
plan back then was how to get those
boxes of our software onto those shelves
or in a world of mobile how to secure a
carrier or OEM deal to get our apps
pre-loaded onto devices today I can
install over a million apps or games
created by tens if not hundreds of
thousands of developers via Google Play
all at the click of a button that's
translated into tens of billions of app
installs and an incredible opportunity
to distribute apps to Android users in
hundreds of countries now in the early
days of Android being fast and launching
first was a pretty solid strategy for
success but as those first 50 apps
quickly grew to hundreds thousands and
now over a million apps it takes a lot
more than speed to stand out from the
crowd
these days the table stakes are a
baseline of quality and a willingness to
create great experiences for all your
users of course app quality can be
somewhat subjective but over the years
we've identified the core criteria that
users identify with apps of high quality
and to make your life easier they're all
available on the Android developer site
for you to review this is the same
checklist that the merchandising team
for Google Play used to ensure only apps
of quality are featured in their
promotions and editors choice categories
and they include everything from
following the app design guideline
two supporting different screen
orientations tablets and other devices
and of course ensuring that your app is
stable and performant so with over a
million apps already available in Google
Play it's no longer just a numbers game
we don't need just more apps or games or
even more developers what we want is
high quality apps from great developers
like you